I am mad [ __ ]
[Music]
it's a good night Monday the 17th if you
didn't pay taxes you're going to jail
who gives a [ __ ] at this point well that
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] do you get that type
action and I'm hanging out with your
buddies look at this
the rooms gonna [ __ ] light on fire
pretty soon
you break the goodnight goodnight
phones are falling shit's happening it
don't mean you're safe feel safe
and some weed for leaders going to blow
nice the night
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
April [ __ ] 17th who's better than you
you're here you made it [ __ ] Easter [ __ ]
the [ __ ] Easter Bunny [ __ ] the
[ __ ] Koreans with the [ __ ] dud
[ __ ] them all this you and me to the
wheels fall off the Church of what's
happened now myself your little
brotherly sigh aunty
don't worry about alright there's no
time for [ __ ] I loves you want to say
hello join the [ __ ] match.com going
deep in this [ __ ] tonight he's
been talking [ __ ] he was in training all
week and I know what he's talking about
hundred milligram edible right now we're
gonna see if he's in training I saved
them this reefer you always gotta be
training this is the one this is the one
there's the one bearable smoke killed
Jesus
hey guys doing uncle Joey here looking
good people I'm happy you're here I'm
mission we got a great episode tonight
we're just warming up the old lungs
let's do this hey you look at this
collection of [ __ ] novelties here you
got this you got the pipe of debt we got
three different titles you got a bag of
reason you got star one you understand
what we're trying to do here there's a
revolution baby if you ain't on don't
worry about it going hang out with some
other people jump up and down let's do
this Lee hit that meal
[Music]
damn me this [ __ ] we're coming up with
people you want to come over you hang
out at the Voodoo Lounge you gotta be
prepared though understand because these
are the long [ __ ] killers here
that's my my next hour-long killer
he's already never Sami what if the
Russians come over and give us this [ __ ]
you're not prepared
give me that [ __ ] bomb we this is it
this is what I'm telling you people is
there anybody out there we gotta [ __ ]
make this happen okay Quigley's here
looking good like a [ __ ] you
wanna [ __ ] around do you wanna hang out
with your little buddies with a hat with
a propeller and talk about Trump and
Hillary or you want to enter the Voodoo
Lounge it's up to you I'm saying you're
sweating from every pore that's the time
this is the [ __ ] John Lennon smoked
before he got shot at if he would have
known he would have smoked this oh [ __ ]
look Kate trying to cause problems diet
squirt that's what Lee likes diets
quitting only Sam we're gonna open up
one of these for you I just smoked
perceived by mistake on a white kind of
fun what's up beautiful
[ __ ] yes smells good this is the House
of Pain
little get the wing gone tonight yeah
I'm saying please leave the [ __ ] so
that break is on record this reef is
really [ __ ] around I got this direct guy
that grows this [ __ ] another planet
another planet just be from you want me
to hit you a percentage Jesus [ __ ] I
don't know about for someone I'm a math
major all I'm telling you is that if it
[ __ ] me out they'll do one of this deal
Whitney had crimes mission focus you
want one we got liquid answers to me go
deep me you and Lila do perfect that's
right you're always good that's what
makes you you are is living on the scan
side you don't say why should I go to
that man's room does he have a gun up
there yeah so you're not that [ __ ]
scared you're not that [ __ ] scared
[ __ ] so Monday night look what
you're doing you just relax him Easter
was yesterday please ready for another
bonnet this this is different this was
different
this is the other favorite this is
[ __ ] oh I always bring Leah's
favorites for days at the hospital he
gets if we OD Thursday night up a toxin
please always prepare I'm saying why
going to the unknown not knowing it you
following me if you're gonna pass out
you know you're gonna wake up in the
hospital room three nurses bubble bath
in your nutsack this is what I'm talking
about you gotta be prepared that's right
you gotta [ __ ] have that insurance
caught on you at all times [ __ ]
take your time but I really look at this
this is least favorite weed of all time
he's told me because you told me variety
of times
hey we go people listen only the best
for my local happy still he say hey you
go oh oh okay what the [ __ ] you think
was giving you flowers up woo baby baby
oh yeah let's do this
this is called boogie with stoop and now
that we gon hit this hit it's not going
gonna be playing against me there you
don't get that [ __ ] there you go that's
the one hey nice I told you this is your
favorite one [ __ ] thinking dealer I
know what Lee likes this fancy eye hit
me with I was supposed to hit Lee with
the Paris first to warm him up and then
hit him with the superglue he likes him
by mistake I went for the superglue and
that song cos [ __ ] rattle you know
I'm saying that's what happens in
Memphis I just gave you Paris which is
[ __ ] traumatic we've got a little bit
of Paris left a little to salute so
super little [ __ ] it's Monday night I
would respect for you if you're not
gonna smoke the best and why are you
doing this [ __ ] you're not gonna eat ass
get off Twitter I told you that thousand
times if you're not gonna smoke the best
when you're gonna have weed still gonna
tell the guy listen don't [ __ ] with me
give me this [ __ ] in the background that
the only smokes and they look at you
like how'd you know about that
what's the code word the code word is I
will [ __ ] take your eye out chew it
and spit it out [ __ ] give me that
good weed no going hey body and [ __ ]
they know they know that you know that
they know that you know yeah I'm saying
that's the most important thing because
they don't need to find that as long as
you know you walk in there assuming that
the other guy knows you'll get the weed
that you deserve
papel myself out of the [ __ ] room it
was like a shotgun blast red aka John FK
I love you [ __ ] seventeen st.
Lazarus number just trying to help you
[ __ ] out here young Sam uncle
joey's always got your back as they say
what else Lisa are you ready for your
second transmission fluid [ __ ] yeah
not those stars you built up a
resistance you little con in the people
you're not even twenty two hundred
milligrams you really to six this will
put you should see look look achieve
[ __ ] sexy beast Joe we gotta look we
got liquid ass if we got PayPass
that's what's a good night tonight your
tights on people want to bother me at
seven o'clock whatever the [ __ ] this is
periscope fable it's a way for young
people joint man
you look beautiful what's been going on
with you look at this [ __ ] boy Patrol
tremendous if you're under 16 I'll hang
up now
does your head's gonna blow up you know
I'm saying if I was fifteen sixteen get
off now take Quigley's on the shown I
don't want no problems you think she's a
second-grade teacher next thing you know
you want to come over to Voodoo Lounge
late that type of the back into the tank
that you stalling
we want from make this we did what we
had to do we gotta hide together right
we showed you cake quickly we say yeah
we [ __ ] TKOs
we ate the cantaloupe [ __ ] hard
toffee 8 100 milliliters gotta get the
heart going somewhere least ambulance
how are you dad you got three there
that's not that's not three [ __ ] to
gushy punches which is four bunch of
milligrams three stars is a thousand
milligrams Ringo know what I'm scared
because my heart has a lovely the first
time I smoked to join this weed by
myself and I was up so I was downstairs
and lovely and guys there's no windows
and my mind went into overdrive my heart
started beating I had sent Matt fuller
on to the store to get me baby aspirin
wasn't good no I get anxiety attacks so
your heart just beats out of control and
once your mind joins in like your mind
the goal may be having a heart attack
heart attack that levels that really
raises the stakes
I have a friend Marco at jujitsu he says
he gets so much anxiety from flying he
would get on a plane and pass out he'd
wake up and they throw he gotta get off
the plane you passed out and that's what
I can I get to the point one not from
flying yeah
why I like a fly [ __ ] backwards make
me throw me out like that little [ __ ]
Chinese dude I got some we feel that
speedy sativa it's blue cookies I always
pick up a few sativas just in case
somebody wants come on the show I didn't
want to smoke as a diamond you got a
[ __ ] nut put some in the bomb
you snorted coke you smoke cigarettes
now it's the same [ __ ] thing
this poor kid over he's a soldier a
deadly saya say what you want to say
about him someday you'll have a picture
lean your houses [ __ ] you'll be showing
your kids Lisa Ali this is a great
[ __ ] man in th stars at that he broke
boundaries I was like that woman number
261 did you see that [ __ ] they tried
to run her off tryna steal a number ran
it again today at the age of 70 yeah
that [ __ ] that shit's the real deal I
advise you to stop running [ __ ]
yeah if you run today you can make it my
Boston my next year you think three days
off eat some clam chowder and you're
ready for the [ __ ] race we're gonna
start this party in ten minutes we'll be
back okay where you at this weekend Tom
nice cupcake Quigley cake quickly this
weekend I'll be at Oxnard Lebanese live
Leo beer next week it'll be in Vegas
beating those [ __ ] out of 20s
at the blackjack table like he does this
show tonight brought to you by lift and
tushy no reason why you ask those who
Smith no reason why your [ __ ] should
stink like death go to tushy right now
and get yourself a [ __ ] nun a little
what are we calling up a day to wash
your [ __ ] yes and your stinky helmet
all right hello Lucy dot-com uncle Joey
loves you
stay black see you at ten minutes Joey
Diaz calm
youtube.com slash see flash Joey Diaz I
see you in ten